Okay, in this next section, we're going to continue our calibration for our lens file.
Now, there is one thing I'd like to do before I go into my Nodal Point calibration.
Instead of using the Unreal Engine as our background, I switch over to our TESOL remote,
and I change my color pattern for this visibility in here from the HDMI output that we're going to get from our wall into just a color.
So for here, I kind of prefer to choose the cyan or blue background.
And I do this so that we can get our object to show up pretty easily on the screen.
So if I switch over, you can see that I'm actually changing the color here between blue and cyan.
I'm going to choose a nice color so that my puck actually shows up really well on the screen itself.
Now, I do want to jump back into Unreal Engine, and from here, I'm going to reopen my lens file.
Now, I can use this, and you can see that I've got my checkerboard and everything else is showing up.
But if I switch back and forth here, I've got a really easy view of my Nodal Point calibration toolset.
Now, before I use this lens file, I actually want to duplicate this.
So let's go ahead and connect to source control, and let's make a copy of our lens file.
Because we've done our lens distortion mapping, and if we want to make any kind of adjustment with our Nodal Point for another camera combination,
it's easier to use the lens distortion map than it is to make a brand new one from scratch.
So again, from here, let's right-click and duplicate, and I'm going to call this one P3NP for Nodal Point.
Now, that means that I'm going to actually need to connect a few other things here.
So let's move this down and select my NDC and my camera, and let's look at our details panel,
and move to our Zeiss Phys data, and we need to make the adjustment so that each of these is actually going to be using our Nodal Point.
And let's make sure that my lens is using the same lens file by selecting that as well.
Now, let's go ahead and mark this for add, just so that we have it active.
And as we're getting ready to do this, I can go back to my Phys information,
and scroll back down to choose my lens file, and make sure that we're actually using the lens file that is active in here.
And I'm going to fill this up with my full screen.
You can see that I've got my position with my focus, my lens, and my distortion parameters are still existing here as well.
Now, I'm going to go into my Nodal Offset tab, because that's the calibration tool that I'm going to use.
I'm going to use my Nodal Offset Points method.
Now, I have multiple values in here, and I'm going to choose my calibrator.
Now, the calibrator is the one that we built in the previous section.
This is our Optipod Track calibrator.
So if I select that, you can see I've got multiple values for my calibrator component, and a calibration point that's in here.
Now, I want to be able to see what's happening, and I don't want any kind of distraction,
so I'm going to make sure that this is fully transparent to see my object.
And to get started, it works just the same as we did before.
It allows me to make sure that my static mesh actor is correctly chosen, and I can see my calibrator.
And now I'm going to have Sean come in and help me move this around after I do my first set of calibration points.
Now, my first set of calibration points should automatically change.
This says calibration point bottom left.
It is the left calibration point of the actual object that we're going to be choosing.
So you can see right over here, I can zoom in just using my middle mouse scroll wheel to do that.
And as I scroll through, I get zoomed in.
I want to get pretty close to the middle in here for my calibration point.
And again, this is the left side of the object, not the left side of the screen.
Now, as I do that, there's my first point, and you can see that changes to my bottom right, so I'm going to hit that next point.
Then I'm going to do the same thing for my center.
And as I mentioned before, I usually put a sticker on the puck so that I can know where the center of my object is.
Then I move up here to my top left, and again, it's the left side of the actual calibration object.
And I'm going to do it again over here for my final one, which is my top right.
Now, you can see that this cycled back through for the calibration point.
And if I move back, I want to move my puck on the stand around in order to get new points.
Now, as you go through and move this, Sean's just going to pick any position that's within the frame.
Now, with that in place, I can just kind of move up a little bit.
I want to make sure that I'm seeing everything, so I want to scroll a little bit higher in there.
And you can see, again, I'm choosing my bottom left, and I'm going to choose my bottom right, and I'm going to choose my center, and my top left, and my top right.
And again, if you're wondering how I know which one, it's actually telling me which calibration point that's in here to choose.
Now, I need Sean to move it again to the opposite side.
These positions can move around. I need eight solid points, or different positions, in front of the camera.
And he's got it set up pretty good right now, actually.
He doesn't need to rotate it at all, because I can see clearly the four points that are in here.
Now I'm going to scroll just a little bit to the top so I can get a better view.
And again, I'm going to create my points.
I'm going to have Sean move it again, and he can lower it down a little bit if he would like, or as low as we can possibly get it.
There. That's kind of what we're looking at for our calibration.
So let's zoom in a little bit, and again, let's move through our points.
Now, as I finish up these points, this is the fourth position that we've actually done.
You can see here, if I look through my list, there's my first set.
And if I scroll down to the bottom, from my bottom left, there's one, two, three, four sections.
So I've got four bottom lefts already, that's four positions.
I need four more.
Now, rather than keep you here for this, we're going to go ahead and skip ahead.
Okay, so now that we've finished our calibration, we need to apply our calibration to the nodal offset that's in here.
So, before we do, we want to be able to see real time what's going on.
So I'm going to switch back over here to my Tesla remote, and I'm going to change back from my pattern to what's visible on the stage.
So you can see now that the blue that was here is back to the stage.
The reason for that is so that I can actually adjust my transparency here and see where my puck is located.
Now, my lime green puck here, you can see it's not quite aligned with the marker.
So if I zoom in here by scrolling with my middle mouse wheel, I just want to make sure that it's clear.
You can see, here's my puck's alignment versus the digital CG object that's in here.
Now, we are ready to apply this, and in order to do that, we just stay in this little window and we move right over to this add nodal offset calibration.
Now, as you're ready to go with this, you just click on this button and all of our points here will get added.
Now, I have more points here than just the eight points that you collect.
I actually would recommend that you collect five to eight points at a specific plane and then move to another plane.
Come forward towards the camera, grab three to five points in that view, and then move the tracked object back a little bit further and grab five points from there as well.
That's going to give us the option so that when we do add this nodal point calibration, we're going to get an RMS number that we're going to try and achieve.
And that RMS number should be below 0.1, so 0.1 or better.
So again, let's go ahead and hit our add to nodal offset calibration, and that's going to give us our RMS reprojection error.
And our error in this case is zero, which is perfect.
So since we've got this nice error here, we're going to go ahead and click OK and apply.
And now when I go ahead and take a look at my transparency, if I scrub through, you can see that it's going to align a lot better.
So there's no more overlay offset here.
Now, to verify that, I am just going to scroll in and zoom in really quickly here, and you can see how that alignment is there.
Now, if I go ahead and have Sean run over to the puck really quickly, we will be able to see if the ghost Sean over there is going to start to move it.
So he just grabs the entire thing and moves it somewhere.
It doesn't matter where.
And then right there, as he moves it, it just follows and lines up back into place.
That tells me that we're actually tracking the object, both in the engine and on the device here, and that the alignment is kind of right where we want it to be.
It also helps by having this sticker realign so that the center of that point here also aligns that way.
Now, really quick, let's go ahead and jump into our slides and review really quickly the nodal point offset calibration.
And I'll point out that this is a separate calibration step that has to be done for your virtual camera transforms,
and it will continue being set by your nodal point of the physical lens as the tracked camera moves within your stage volume.
Now, as I showed you just a moment ago, the offset application in here, just to verify it,
you just change your transparency from 0 to 0.5.
You move your OptiPak track object, whatever your tracked object is, around.
It should track and superimpose itself correctly over the physical object.
If not, you can go ahead and remove this nodal point lens file and replace it and do it again.
Just get a few more points to calibrate this time, and you should be good to go.
Now, one thing to note before we finish up here,
if you did not set up time code in Genlock and adjusted the synchronations using the time data monitor,
there might be lag in your CG element as you move.
There should always be a little bit, but when you stop moving, even if there is any kind of lag,
your CG element will line up again if it's done correctly.
Okay, so that's it for your nodal point calibration.
Now we are going to move on to your LED wall alignment,
and we'll finish up that next section after we build our Arrucos markers.